They're epically cool.
And living the lives that we all strive to live.
For decades, The San San Dieguito's Boogie Board Club
has met every week to catch some waves together
and today they're here to tell us about it.
So please welcome Fran Dyer, Christa Stahl,
Carol German, and Charlotte Gumbrell.
(audience applauding)
Well hello.
We're so excited to speak with you guys today,
Fran and Christa, you're the founders
of this whole operation.
May I ask, how did it start?
Well, it started in 2002.
Christa and I were at a Weight Watchers meeting
and the Weight Watcher meeting was right on the ocean.
We were at the top of a bluff
and we had 150 steps to walk down to the ocean.
And so I said, "Christa, after the meeting's over,
"why don't we start going in the ocean?
"Why don't we grab some boogie boards
"and just go and play?"
And three other women joined us and we began.
And that is 19 years ago.
And Christa, tell us all about your experience with it.
Well, it's pretty much the same.
The club that we belong to is a newcomer's club.
And I was new to the area.
I retired and I had relocated.
And so it really was a nice meeting up
and it's been consistent ever since then.
Fran, I think you've kept me going.
And perhaps me too.
Carol, you joined the club 15 years ago
after a boogie boarding injury, but it didn't stop you.
Can you tell us about that?
Well, I also was new to the area
and really didn't know very many people
and I live right on the ocean.
I can look out my window and see it anytime I want
but I wasn't going in because I had broken a number
of bones boogie boarding in Hawaii.
Oh wow.
These ladies, when I got to know them
through the main, the big club,
the newcomers club, said, "Come on in the ocean with us."
And Christa was really one of my heroes
because she's a little older than I am.
And I thought, if Christa can do this, I can do it too.
So they kind of talked me back into the water.
And I'm so glad they did
because it keeps us young and healthy.
I love this so much because I feel like
so many times people just get boring as they get older
and they don't try new things.
And I know Charlotte, you're one of the most senior
of the boogie boarders, right?
Tell us how you got into this.
Well, actually I wish I'd known about this group earlier.
I boogie boarded pretty much with my teenage children.
We use to use the canvas things.
And then all of a sudden somebody invented the boogie board
and oh my golly, what a wonderful thing that was.
So I bought it for grandchildren.
And then I decided that,
hey I'm the one who really loves to boogie board.
So I've been doing it ever since.
I think I'm on my fourth board.
What's the best thing about it?
I just have to ask, what really rocks it for you, Charlotte?
Well, in a very short time,
I feel like my brain is alive.
I'm alive and life is worth living.
You know, it doesn't take much time
in that water to feel that way.
Boogie boarding is a wonderful sport,
up until, I keep thinking this is my last year
but I'm still doing it.
You know, friends are everything.
And the way that you guys show up for each other
and for life in general, is just inspiration to us all.
And thank you for coming to talk here today
with us so that we can look to you guys
on how we're supposed to live our lives.
(audience applauding)
Thank you for having us.
Thank you so much, we love it.
Thank you Fran, and Christa and Carol and Charlotte.
Thank you
for showing us the way.
Thank you so much.
And cowabunga, we're coming to get ya.
I'll see ya on the waves ladies.
(laughing)
Bye bye.
Thank you so much.
(upbeat music)